hi everybody
I'm Ellie powers and I'm a product
manager here on the Google Play team and
as Shannon mentioned what I'm here to
talk about is what's happening in
Android development in 2016 it's kind of
amazing from Edie to even say that
because you know we talked about the
Android platform and it feels so
immediate to me I've been at Google
almost five years and when I joined that
platform was very new it's come a huge
way a very very long way and I'm excited
today to share with you some of the
things that were most excited about and
some of the things that we think that
you need to know about its developers in
order to make the best apps possible so
Android development is a lot more
sophisticated this year than it was back
in the past and that's really important
and it's happening because users have
much higher expectations than ever
users want apps that are innovative that
are highly functional that are beautiful
and take advantage of all the latest
technologies now as a developer you want
to give them all of that you want to
make those great user experiences but
you want to have the least amount of
hassle possible totally and that's why
you need more sophisticated tools that
are going to bring you more power so
today I'm going to talk about four
different areas of Android development
first we're going to talk about the
latest Android dessert nougat it's
sticky it's sweet it might get stuck in
your teeth and it's got a lot of great
new features that users are going to
love we're going to talk about what you
need to know as a developer second we're
going to talk about what's new with
material design it launched a couple
years ago and there's some new things
that you should know about third we're
going to talk about Android studio
that's another product that's been
progressing a lot so we're going to talk
about how that can help you build better
apps and finally we had a huge
announcement this year at Google i/o
about firebase firebase means a lot more
this year than it did last year and
we're going to go through a lot of the
features that it offers it's all about
building and growing your apps
cross-platform so we're going to talk a
little bit more about how that can help
you with your overall app business
including Android but also beyond it so
first let's talk about Android nougat
has anyone here tried Android nougat so
far it's got a build on one of your
devices that's great so you may have a
favorite feature but I'm going to tell
you a few of mine one of my favorite
things about it is the improved battery
life
and another one is when you upgrade to a
new version and saw an update it does
need to go back and optimize all your
apps anymore that's one of my favorite
things especially because I have like
150 apps on my phone so those are
features that are great for users and
now we're going to walk through the
things that are most important to know
about as a developer so first up is
multi-window
what this means as a user can use their
phone or tablet or even TV to to more
than one thing at the same time now this
can be great for users who like to do
things like maybe watching a video of
the cooking recipe demonstrating how to
make an item while looking at the recipe
or the shopping list in another screen
so you can look at those two activities
at the same time maybe if you're like me
when you're doing your work email you
also like to watch cat videos at the
same time and so multi-window will help
you do that
we find that mostly window works
especially well with devices that have
much larger screens I use it on my Nexus
6p and find it works pretty well there
and it's really easy to have this work
it'll start working on your apps
automatically by default you don't
actually have to do anything but in
order to make sure it works well you'll
probably want to test out your apps with
nougat in the multi window mode and just
make sure that everything is working
well and looking good and the reason
this works so easily is that Android
apps and their layouts are so good at
adjusting anyway to take advantage of
different screen sizes right if you open
your app on a different sized device
it'll adjust automatically and so with
multi window a similar thing is
happening here now after you've tested
it if you want to make a few tweaks
there are certain parameters that you
can change like things like default or
minimum sizing if you want to make sure
it works exactly right so next up
notifications marshmallow had a big
notifications overhaul and a nougat we
still weren't satisfied as we decided to
do even more stuff we're going to talk
through a few of the important changes
so first up there's new templates for
notifications another really important
thing is there is a attribution marker
you can see up here there's a green icon
and it says hangouts this way a user can
be sure exactly which app sent that
notification also we offer bundled
notifications I use this all the time
because I get a lot of gmail messages
and so with bundled notifications they
all come together as one group so it's
easier for the user to manage those
notifications
but my favorite feature with
notifications in nougat is actually
these quick actions if you look at the
screen shot in the right what you can
see here is are these quick action
buttons so if you get a message you
don't actually have to open the app to
reply to it for example here I could
just click on the reply button or the
archive button and so when I find that
I'm running from meeting a meaning it's
really easy for me to send quick
messages to my colleagues or friends and
family as I'm going through my day so
does anyone here in this room speak
multiple languages yeah I had a feeling
that this would be a big hit in Europe I
speak one language pretty well and then
two languages pretty badly and so we
think in Europe this is going to be a
pretty popular feature so the idea is
that many people don't speak just one
language they speak more and so what we
allow the user to do is to specify their
different languages that they speak and
put them in their order of preference so
when a user tries to open an app Android
will try to load the app in the users
first-choice language if that app
translation isn't available in that
language they'll load the second choice
the third choice and so on so for
example in this case with this screen
here it would first try to open the app
in English if that didn't work it would
try Spanish and then as a last resort it
would try French so as a developer there
shouldn't be anything that you have to
do to make this work it should just work
automatically but we think that you'll
like knowing that this is available and
that this will help users be able to
make sure they're seeing your app in the
right language that's right for them
so in marshmallow we talked last year
about a huge overhaul to the permissions
platform permissions are now real-time
as of marshmallow but there were a
couple things we wanted to tweak to make
them work even better so has anyone ever
had to ask for the permission to access
a user's internal storage and it used to
pop up a message about hey can I access
your photos and this and that and a
bunch of different things we had a lot
of feedback from developers that
sometimes they would only need to access
one of these things and gain access to
all of these things was concerning to
users and we thought that that was
absolutely great feedback so what we've
done is we've broken it down so that as
a developer rather than in requesting
access to all of the storage you can
request access to a specific folder so
for example in this case maybe this is a
photo app and so it's actually asking to
access just the pictures folder and so
this means that it
user understands a lot better why what
you're requesting is is necessary and
also you're not gaining access to other
files that you may not need to have
access to so does anyone here in this
room work on 3d games yeah couple folks
that's really cool so volcn is a new
technology it's a low level low overhead
and cross-platform 3d API and it's also
available in the Android nougat as well
so this is a really great technology
that helps if you're trying to write
games that work cross-platform it works
a lot more similarly across these
different platforms and also if you use
a game engine a lot of engines are
supporting it already or have a platform
to be able to support Vulcan in the
future so what this means now with
Vulcan being supported and nougat is if
you are using Vulcan it'll start to work
really well on these devices right away
so that was Android nougat and now we're
going to move on and talk about what's
new in material design so first of all
how many apps here are using material
design already good number of folks so
if you're using material design you're
actually in a really good company
we noticed recently that we have
basically a million apps on the Play
Store that are using material design and
if you haven't heard of it what material
design is is a set of principles that
govern how acts how apps look how they
move how they feel and it's this instead
of design principles that covers things
like tactile surfaces rich imagery bold
colors and my favorite which is
meaningful motion and why material
design is important for you as a
developer is that when a person uses
your app for the first time you want
them to know how it works right and if
you're already using this material
design framework that users understand
it'll be more intuitive to them to
understand how to get started with your
app you'll be less likely to have a
person who gets confused or lost and
doesn't know how to do it and so if
you're looking to reach the over 1.4
billion Android users that are active
today you know using material design can
be a critical part of the process in
order to make sure that they're going to
know how to get started immediately and
stay engaged so we'll talk about a
couple examples of developers here in
Europe that are using material design so
first up is bring from Switzerland and
they've implemented material design now
if you haven't used the bring app it's
all about being able to manage
notable shopping lists and it does
things like informing you about what
items still need to go in your cart you
can also share your shopping lists so if
you have a roommate or spouses at the
store you can alert them at the last
minute if there's something that they
need to pick up from you
so bring is use material design to
implement a consistent toolbar across
the different screens in their app it
allows them to keep their most popular
features accessible wherever you go
and so they've managed to fit in search
the nav drawer imagery and an invite
button on this toolbar that's visible
throughout their app and they were
pretty happy with how this went because
when they launched it they saw that they
had a 66% increase in session times in
the six months following the launch of
the material design revamp and they also
managed to get showcased on the material
up blog as well
fabulous is another app this one is
based in Paris and it's a science-based
app that encourages users to adopt a
healthy lifestyle and it does this by
developing a personalized step by step
program for each user and so in this
layout we can see that they're using
cards as well but in this case they're
using this to help a user organize their
habits and their goals and when you tap
on these cards they elevate and with the
help of icons that make it really easy
for the users to see exactly what
they're doing and to understand every
action that they're taking it's very
clear layout and users have responded
really well so since they did their
material redesign in 2015 they've
actually had a tenfold increase in daily
downloads so they've been really happy
with this results as well so let's talk
about what's new with material design
this year when we first introduced it
you know we had some devices that were
able to support a lot of advanced
complicated things but some devices
weren't the great news that in 2016 on
average devices are just so much more
powerful than they were when material
was first announced so we're really
encouraging developers this year who
want to really set themselves apart from
a design standpoint to look at the use
of motion with the higher-end devices
you can support a lot more motion than
you could with lower end devices a
couple of years ago so motion is really
powerful because not only can it be fun
can it be amusing can it really bring
charm and character to your brand but
it's also a real usability feature using
motion in your hat can help a user
understand as they trigger a transition
from one screen in your app to the next
really how
understand the transitions and as I
mentioned it's also a great way to bring
in fun delight and even make your users
laugh so that was what's new with
material design in 2016 and now the
question is how do I make this happen if
I want to support the latest nougat
features bring a great design and build
a wonderful app that's really going to
get noticed how do I do it let's talk
about Android studio for that so as
anyway you're using Android studio today
is anyone not using Android studio cool
every year we're seeing more and more
people using the studio and the reason
for that we hope is that we wanted to
build a purpose focused IDE we wanted to
have something that really was tuned for
the languages that Android development
is based on and really felt native to
the Android platform and we've really
been shocked and humbled by the amount
of momentum we've seen on the Android
studio adoption so far so those of you
who said you're using Android studio
you're in very good company if we look
at the top 125 apps and games on Play
actually 92% of them are using Android
studio that's been great to see and of
course millions of developers all over
the world are using Android studio as
well so for those of you who maybe
didn't know Android studio as well let's
take a little bit of time to talk about
it and talk about what was new in the
past year so at the beginning of the
year we launched Android studio 2.0 the
main focus here was speed that was a
real key piece of feedback we had from
developers they said make it faster if
you do nothing else came back time and
time again so we introduced something
called
instant run now the idea here is that
you can do swaps of code in real time
when you go to run your app there's not
a lot of waiting and it can push code
and resources directly into the app
while it's running on your computer
and this also included not just instant
run but also major improvements to the
emulators it included a new emulator AP
UI a GPU profiler view search deep
linking creation and building of test
cases we'll talk about those things a
little bit later and then in 2.1 we
built that release side-by-side with a
team working on nougat so this is all
about supporting Android nougat so we
have support for the new features and
api's new nougat emulators
test on Jack compiler support so that
you can try ends Java eight support and
important stability enhancements that
was something else we heard from you is
that every time we need to update it we
need to make sure it's just really high
quality productions grade stuff and then
in 2.1 we also made an additional
investment into instant run we move the
decks in process and that was a huge
accelerator allowing instant run to get
even faster than previous incarnations
so of course now we're looking at
Android studio 2.2 the main focus is
there are speed smarts and support for
nougat and so we also have a ton of
updates in this release everything from
firebase integration to enhance support
from C++ so I'm going to highlight a few
things that you should know about in
this latest release so with the
developer one of the best feelings in
the world is being in the flow you know
you finally sort of load up in your
brain all the code that's running you're
working on it and the last thing you
want is to get disrupted to break that
flow when you're waiting for your app to
build and run on your machine so that's
why we introduced instant run and we've
made progressive improvements since its
launched you can see a lot of the
updates here into the speed and that's
really been getting a lot of good
feedback and we're going to keep trying
to work on that improving it even
further we've also seen a big
development in the Android ecosystem
around C++ when we first started working
on Android we thought that native code
was something that was going to be
pretty rare and it was and then as
androids evolved we actually seen more
and more developers using C++ for more
and more reasons initially would just be
for things like maybe physics
simulations but we've seen over time
that more and more types of apps and
games are using native code so we've
realized we need to enhance the support
for it a lot more so you can now
actually do a whole bunch of more things
in C++ and let's walk through a few of
them
so we've already supported editing and
debugging of native code but with 2.2
we're bringing you IntelliJ 2016 point 1
this includes a lot of intelligence
enhancements to C++ from the sea lion
2016 release and now you can also just
run the app like any normal app Android
app using the run dialogue it's much
more integrated the overall build and
run experience so now this is also
integrated with the debugger so that you
can set the breakpoint then run the app
and the debugger will break at the right
place executing the code on your machine
it's just a much more integrated well
run test run and build cycle on your
machine so next I'd also want to tell
you a little bit more about the C++
debugger enhancements so in 2.2 you no
longer have to select explicitly whether
you want to C++ a Java or a hybrid
debugger you can just choose auto and
then the IDE will automatically select
the the right debugger for what you're
trying to do and if you're debugging
code and and above you can actually just
use one debugger for both of these
thanks to our Java aware C++ debugger so
let's talk about design you know we
talked a little bit earlier about how
users respond so well when you've made
your app look great an Android studio
has introduced a couple of new features
to really help you improve this so first
of all the layout editor it's a new user
interface designer it helps you quickly
design the layouts in your app in a much
more visual way a much more interactive
way and so you don't have to go back and
forth so much between coding and
previews we also have some new features
here you can see the blueprint mode it's
really powerful and we have a new
properties panel also over there which
allows you to quickly edit the layouts
and the widgets faster we've also to
introduce a new type of layout
it's called constraint layout previously
we'd see a lot of developers when they
wanted to achieve a very precise layout
they end up nesting a bunch of different
layout types inside of each other it
would be very hard to debug very clunky
we've all probably spent a few hours
fiddling with these things wondering why
it never quite lines up right and so
what we've done with constraint layout
is it gives you a lot more powerful
language to express complex UI's but you
don't have to do this horrible layout
nesting anymore so we think this will
really simplify your experience for
creating and managing your apps and
together with the layout editor you'll
be able to have a much more powerful and
simple way of modifying your layouts now
if you do have a tricky layout issue
that you can't really figure out we also
have something called layout inspector
now the idea here is that you can debug
a snapshot of your applet your apps
layout you can have it running on your
Android emulator on your computer or on
your Android device and it'll gives you
tools to inspect the view hierarchy and
you can look at different corresponding
attributes to find and fix the
out issues that you couldn't debug a
little bit more easily so another thing
that a lot of developers are trying to
do is to get more efficient with their
apps not just in how they build them but
also on the binaries that are delivered
to users devices so the tool that you
have it's best for this is called apk
analyzer it's really designed to help
you keep your apps small and efficient
and for those of you who are building
apps for emerging markets places like
India Brazil and Indonesia this becomes
even more critical as users don't have a
ton of storage and also have limited
network connectivity we'll give you a
little bit more information about that
in the building for billions exercise so
apk inspector can help you figure out
which of the different files in your apk
are taking up a lot of space it can also
help you do things like avoiding the 64
K reference method limit issues with
your Dex files it can help you diagnose
ProGuard config issues and inspect
complex resources files it's really to
help you analyze every aspect of your
apk and get rid of the bloat now one of
the other things to note is that the apk
analyzer actually shows you file size in
a couple of different ways first of all
you can see the raw file size but
actually you can also see the download
size of various components in your apk
and what is the difference between those
well the download size is actually the
estimated size that users would actually
need to download when the apk is served
from Google Play and that can actually
be different from the raw file size so
this information should really help you
prioritize where to focus your efforts
in reducing app size and make sure that
you're doing the highest return on
investment there so let's move on and
talk about testing right testing is
really critical the most basic thing
that users want is they want your app to
work well and so you know writing UI
tests can be really tedious and a lot of
developers have this as their least
favorite thing to do and we wanted to
make that easier because testing is so
critical and so important when you're
trying to get a high star rating on
Google Play or trying to create an app
that users love and will want to come
back to so we created something really
new we created something called the
record espresso test UI in Android
studio so here's what you can do it's
just as easy as using your app you can
run your app and then Android studio
will I should capture all of your UI
interactions
and it'll convert them into a fully
reusable espresso test and then you can
run this test locally with Android
studio maybe using the emulator or you
can actually run it against firebase
test lab which we'll talk about a little
bit later and so if you want to use the
recorder you can just go to the run menu
and select the Accord espresso test
function so if you have been sort of
procrastinating and putting off writing
any tests because it's a big pain which
it is I would highly encourage you to
use the espresso test recorder to get
started if you just record a couple
simple tests for the most common flows
in your app that can pay off hugely when
you're trying to make sure you don't
have any regressions of functionality
also Korda testing is having a great
local test solution an emulator right
and the Android emulator didn't use to
be as fast as we wanted it to be and so
users will tell me a developers would
tell me they spend a ton of time and
money trying to source a whole wide
range of devices when I'd go to visit
developers in their offices they would
show me a gigantic drawer or maybe even
a full closet full of all the Android
devices that they had to buy probably a
lot of you have one of those closets as
well so we've wanted to try to make this
unnecessary or at least a lot less
necessary so what we've been doing is
focusing on improving the emulator one
of the biggest concerns there was speed
we've now improved the emulator so it's
actually faster than a physical device
we're really excited about that and you
know we hope that being able to use more
of your testing on emulators will mean
that you don't have to spend as much
time and money managing your gigantic
drawer of Android devices and you can
spend more of your time doing some of
the funner parts finally Android studio
is also the easiest way to integrate the
suite of firebase tools that I'm about
to talk about we want to make it easier
for you to add services like analytics
authentication notifications and AdMob
with just a couple clicks and in Android
Studios we've made that a lot easier
okay so I started talking a little bit
about firebase and how it integrates
with Android studio but let's talk about
actually what firebase is so firebase
was a company that Google acquired a
couple years ago and when we acquired
them they were actually mostly like kind
of back-end services and now at Google
i/o this year we were really excited to
announce that firebase is a lot more
than that firebase is actually a whole
suite of technologies we've tried to
bundle together all of the most
and Google developer services and
created one cross-platform suite of
tools it used to be if you wanted to use
a bunch of different developer services
from Google you had to go to a bunch of
different places
multiple SDKs multiple websites of
documentation it was more complicated
than we wanted but with firebase we've
combined a bunch of the different
components together you know single SDKs
centralized hubs of documentation etc so
it's a lot easier for you as a developer
to use multiple Google tools together
and one key point to note firebase is
cross-platform it'll work fantastic on
Android but we know all of you want to
support your app on multiple platforms
as well and so firebase also works on
iOS so let's talk about the thing that
brings together all the different
firebase tools
Analytics it's at the core everything
you want to do as a developer you also
want to measure and see how it impacts
users so there firebase analytics
product is great about giving you
information about how users behave and
also where they're coming from when they
go into your app we built it from
scratch to support app developers
cross-platform and a lot of people ask
us well how is it different from Google
Analytics and I think the key thing to
know about it is it was built by the
same team that built Google Analytics
firebase analytics is super optimized
for mobile apps and we think it's a
great place to get started if you
haven't picked a solution already or if
you're looking at getting a better
analytics product for apps and games so
here's an example of what firebase
analytics can look like with a
particular game and then one of the
things we wanted to do with firebase
analytics is to make sure that out of
the box you get as much information as
possible so you don't have to spend a
bunch of time duplicating the sorts of
things that every developer would want
to have so it's a great way to look at
for example the usage from your app you
can also do experiments with analytics
and in a lot of cases you won't even
need to do any coding so for those of
you who work at smaller companies you
know it's really great to set these
sorts of things up so that people like
product managers and marketing folks can
run experiments or get data without
always having to ask engineering teams
to go and add more code to the app so
that was analytics and now we're going
to zoom in in a couple of different
parts of the firebase suite to
understand more about that and we'll
start with develop I've listed a bunch
of the different technologies here that
firebase offers unfortunately I don't
have time to
about them all today so we're going to
focus on a couple things first up is
authentication one of the most common
things developers want users to do in
their app is to sign in because that way
you can offer the user a personalized
experience that evolves with them as
they keep using your app and so firebase
authentication gives you a bunch of
different options
it supports email and password login it
supports Google Facebook Twitter and
github sign-in and if you already have
an existing system it can integrate with
those existing user accounts and
firebase authentication has an
open-source library and it's fully
integrated with other firebase features
as well so just as an example if you use
firebase authentication you can also use
it to control access to user data in the
real time database so firebase Cloud
messaging which was formerly known as
Google Cloud messaging is a
cross-platform messaging solution that
lets you deliver messages to users in a
reliable way
and with no cost and also trying to
minimize impact on users battery life
firebase test lab for Android is a great
way to catch bugs before you ship your
code to users we talked about this a
little bit before how you can record
tests on Android studio and firebase
test lab it's really important to know
that's actually running your tests on
real physical devices that are located
in a data center at Google now if you
want to get started with firebase test
lab actually the best way to do it is to
go into the Google Play Developer
console we have something in there
called the pre-launch report which we're
actually going to hear a little bit more
about later we definitely encourage you
to try the pre-launch report in the
developer console and to be able to use
it with all of your alpha and beta apps
now while you may try to catch most of
your issues and bugs through testing
before the launch we all know that we're
not always 100% effective in this right
so firebase crash reporting is a great
way to find out about issues that are
occurring in the field after your launch
so whenever an app crashes it's reported
by firebase crash and the developer can
review these in a report again this also
works cross-platform so you can use it
across all of your apps so that was
developing an app and now let's talk
about some of the technologies to help
grow an app
first up is dynamic links I was just
talking to a developer about this
yesterday you know a lot of us want to
be able to provide a single link that
works cross-platform and also to be able
to deep link someone to a page within an
app even if that user had to go through
the install flow and this is really
helpful these links can work across
different platforms and they do carry
the URL state after the user has
completed the install and also they're
integrated with firebase analytics so
you can also see the activity that's
coming in through these dynamic links an
app indexing this is a we this is
something we launched a couple years ago
it's integrated with firebase as well
and this is a great way to be able to
take content for your app and surface it
to users within Google search and also
as users interact with your app it can
also boost your search ranking in Google
search it also provides things like
autocomplete in the search bar bringing
users into the content for your app
really easily indirectly in
notifications so firebase notifications
is a free service a lot of developers
ask me how can I manage these better and
this is a good solution for it it gives
a simple UI for generating notifications
a lot of the time you don't even need to
write code you can just use the firebase
notifications console so again this is a
great way where if you have multiple
people working on your app even folks
who don't do coding on a daily basis can
still go in and set up new notifications
so on the client for Android no coding
is needed for background notifications
and if you want to do notifications on
iOS or foreground notifications there's
just a little bit of coding required
there also you can see you know you want
to be really sure as a developer that
you're not sending too many
notifications or having users feel like
they're getting spammed so you can
actually look at analytics to be able to
track conversion rates on these
notifications you can understand which
ones are effective and which ones might
not be as welcome so that's how to build
and grow your app finally the most
important part perhaps earning money so
AdMob is a popular way to be able to
mobile monetize your mobile apps through
advertising and now it's been brought
together in the same suite of tools to
make it a lot easier to integrate with
in firebase there's a number of
different ad formats if you haven't
tried AdMob yet we have video ads we
have
native ads we have interstitial ads and
we're seeing over 1 million apps using
AdMob today and again it's fully
integrated with firebase but if you're
already using AdMob already you can
still start using it without having to
adjust or mess up your existing AdMob
configuration ok so that was my talk
today we talked about what's new in
Android development in 2016 first we
talked about nougat we talked about our
latest version of the Android release we
talked about improvements to the user
experience things like multi window
multiple languages notifications and a
couple tweaks the permissions flow next
we talked about material design it's
very quickly becoming the default and
the user expectation we have over a
million apps using it today and actually
the thing we want to focus on this year
if you're thinking of refining your
material design implementation is
talking about bringing in more motion to
make your app easier to use and also to
make it a lot more fun and add
personality third we talked about
Android studio we have instant run it's
a lot faster to use but we also have
important new features around the areas
of design things like the new constraint
layout to help you simplify complex
layouts and also the emulator to help
you do testing a lot more quickly so
that's what we learned about an Android
development but I think our biggest
announcement for this year was firebase
this cross-platform suite of tools is
really powerful to help you build great
Android apps and also great iOS apps I
think a lot of developers are trying to
manage multiple apps across multiple
platforms and with firebase it's a lot
simpler to get all the best things that
you want from Google with a lot less of
the hassle all right
you